bon les séries gt clash et non or
quelqu'un que j'aime énormément et ça
m'a peiné non je vous dire je le cite un
chanteur que j'aime ça fait mal une
certaine une certaine sarah sarah fresu
un ami l'a dit c'est en plus à jacky
fond oui je kiffe sahara présentée et je
vous dise ça m'a fait mal de voir ça
sarah fresu ces actes hors studio sarah
fresu s'il te plaît ne me lâche pas
regarder ce qu'elle a dit regardez pas
ce qui pose problème c'est à cause de ce
genre d'émission qui déclarent des
sommes incroyables en plein écran que le
lendemain nous
c'est en france nous on se fait voler en
france tout ça c'est à cause d'eux en
fait ça veut dire que en fait à quoi ça
va changer d'avis de savoir quelle
influence heures prend combien dans ces
cas là au lieu de parler des salaires
des influenceurs et de ceci et de cela
et de ceux ci les doutes là
mais anouma
mehdi le salaire que tu vois tu pas avec
des bm et passe voilà et là moi ça m'a
retourné quoi alors bien sûr vous
attendez que je dise mon salaire sur tp
mp oui
ouais non non non il faut pas énerver on
va pas alors à l'apport rapport avec
nous c'est une ancienne candidate
candidat à son prénom sa fraise ou non
son vrai nom de sarata non mais ils sont
sympas mais ils sont en train de
s'exhiber constamment sur instagram
montrant des maisons des voitures des
trucs et c'est assez normal qu'on
s'intéresse à leur train de vie et qu'on
révèle qui viennent beaucoup d'argent
c'est un secret pour personne enfin pu
voir c'est un secret pour personne c'est
vrai voilà et moi j'aime sarah fresu
quoi qu'il arrive
et voilà en plus je vois que ça et vous
benjamin vous avez un point commun la
bouche c'est excellent